hey you guys we're doing a movie review
again
this is the one that won the patreon
poll by again a quite a large margin
and i was kind of excited because i've
been wanting to rewatch this one
yeah movie aged pretty well i saw it
when it came out saw the driving
oh yeah i think i don't think i saw it
in the theater i think i saw it uh
on cable maybe like a couple of years
later this is pumpkin head
from 1988 yeah and this is actually
notable for being the first and i
believe only film that was directed
by stan winston stan winston obviously a
special effects legend he died back in
2008
he did the effects for terminator uh
aliens
first two predator movies first three
jurassic park movies
iron man edward scissorhands he's done
like [ __ ]
just [ __ ] tons of special effects work
so i guess what happened with this one
was that
um i think the script was you know
generator whoever owned it was like
the dino de laurentiis production
company and i think they sent him the
script
with the understanding that he would do
the effects on it
but he was kind of like hey can i direct
it because i've wanted to
i've always wanted to direct as they all
say so they let him direct it but for
whatever reason
he didn't direct anymore i don't know if
he didn't enjoy the experience or
because i think this movie i don't think
it did super great
but it definitely got enough of a cult
following that it now has
three sequels and had a comic book and a
video game adaptation and [ __ ] like that
so even though it's not as well known a
horror franchise
as you know halloween or nightmare on
elm street or whatever um
it's still kind of one of the one of the
lesser franchises i guess
in the sense of like not being quite as
popular i think it came out the summer
after i graduated from high school i
think i had already graduated
yeah it was 88 when it came out yeah we
saw it
when it was new um and we all liked it
so you know when it came to teenage guys
we liked it we talked about it for a
long time well yeah it's a great premise
and honestly i think it made money
because it only cost like three million
dollars to make
you know what i mean we like the monster
it kind of looked like alien
well it's the same guy yeah it had it
had uh
it was we thought that it had real
respectable um
storyline and real respectable special
effects it seemed to be like a big
budget movie when we saw it
um but like we were young too at the
time like there's a lot of little
nuances to this movie that
i didn't pick up on back then yeah like
uh
the fact that this really isn't set in
any kind of real
historical period i mean all your
country people look like something out
of the damn dust bowl like like the 20s
but it's supposed to be in the 80s and
all the city people are [ __ ] you know
regular 80s people and the location is
unknown i mean i'm looking around i'm
looking at the terrain and i'm like
that's california yeah they shot in
california right
but they're acting like they're in
[ __ ] appalachia or
or you know yeah malaysia or [ __ ]
maybe louisiana somewhere i mean
appalachian that's the
ex that's the impression i got although
i think
that i mean and i think even when i
first saw it because like i said i
didn't see it in the theater but i saw
it like a couple years later like in the
early 90s like on cable and just the
impression i got was that
this is very much like a campfire tale
or it's it's like folkloric
so i almost kind of had more so it's not
really supposed to be anywhere or at any
particular
time in reality yeah it's like a fairy
tale story
story you're being told yeah which is
one of the best things about it i think
i mean um nobody in 88
anywhere in the united states walked
around wearing rags and live
filled like whole towns of them
especially not in california
you know not even in appalachia did they
look that i mean
there were you know all the cars were
they had were from the 50s and
you know the goats and the chickens and
the little pens and i'm going
to they've all kind of like had they're
barefoot and they all yeah barefoot
and we all have that you know what i
mean so it's it's it's
a it's a fanciful tale well yeah it's
like hillbilly folklore yeah
everybody in it is some kind of a
stereotype like you know you got your
city guido and he's the bad guy and then
you got all these [ __ ] like
i guess you just kind of call them
mainstream white girls you know
basic [ __ ] and uh you know and then
kind of nerdy guy
and then you go to the uh
to the country people and they're all
like pretty stereotypical
uh beverly hillbilly type characters you
know what i mean that
maybe existed in the 20s but probably
only existed
that way through the eyes of hollywood
directors i mean some of it is kind of
accurate but that's not what they're
trying to do with this movie they're
they're trying to show a big difference
between two different cultures and like
a cultural
conflict and that this is happening in
some
remote nook and cranny of the world that
you don't know about and [ __ ]
they got a witch and a damn demon
working for him yeah sure and
so i didn't you know back in 88 i didn't
realize how unrealistic this was
i just accepted it i see it now i was
like wait a minute hold on
two different time periods well see i
was just accepted because like i said to
me it just sounded like a campfire story
yeah
like something you would tell and it was
like really crazy like around halloween
it's just like we have this legend
around these parts of this demon named
pumpkinhead that'll come and get you if
so if you do something bad to somebody
and she'll i mean that's a great premise
i really like
folkloric uh horror movies
and this is kind of a really really good
example of that
that's too that was too sophisticated
for me back in 88.
for me the damn screen was like an eye
whatever they showed me was the truth so
this is happening somewhere
you know what i mean i didn't really
think of it as that it was a mythical
tale taking place in a mythical universe
but once i saw it i realized what they
were doing now is it
is it a fun movie yeah it's good too
it's got
it's got some really cool like
paranormal witchcraft type stuff going
on
about vengeance and summoning a demon
to so you can get vengeance and then the
price for the vengeance and the [ __ ]
witch that's
that you know and then the more i could
do for you ed harley you know
gonna have to write it out it has to run
it yeah
yeah you gotta run his cars now see
there's not enough movies with
scary old witches in them i say that all
the time but this has a scary old witch
in it she's not even like the main
villain because pumpkin hat
is but so so what you have like at the
very beginning i still don't know who
plays that uh that which but that's
actually really cool and
i should say too obviously since dan
winston uh did i think his team did all
of the uh
effects on it but he was the one that
directed it the pumpkin head monster
looks amazing yeah it looks good
and if they have like a lot of really
good um you know full body shots of him
but that's a dude and a c
yeah it's a no it's not cgi it's a suit
it looks real though
it's really it looks like a real
creature it's as good as the xenomorph
from aliens it's just a little bit
different
and it changes sometimes it's got ed
harley's face on it and sometimes it
switches around because it can look
through hit he can
he's forced to see the vengeance through
the eyes of the monster when when the
monster is doing the killing
but the monster can almost also the
demon can also reach out and look
through ed harley's [ __ ] eyes
to try to find future victims and stuff
it's pretty cool there's like weird
angles
and then um i don't know just
the hillbilly characters or trip uh well
one of the things i like about this
dialogue is realistic yeah i mean is
that even though like you said at the
beginning you have
kind of a standard horror movie set up
where you have city folks versus
hillbillies
um although in this sense like the
hillbillies are kind of more the good
guys and the city people are kind of the
bad guys
which just has kind of been done before
ed harley's kind of like the example of
the moral example of the tale of that
[ __ ] vengeance isn't worth it
that's that's yeah he's kind of the
tragic but i like that even the bad guys
like the city folks
even though they do something shitty
well not even all of them just that one
does something shitty like at the
beginning
um as it goes on like sort of depths and
nuances to their characters are all kind
of introduced
but it's it's that's why i think it's
like a really kind of cool thing so the
setup of it
at the first uh the first scene is like
a flashback sort of thing
and that's take place in 1957 and that's
when
um lance hendrickson's character had
harley
when he was a kid and he's remembering
back to
one night when his parents were you know
putting him to bed or whatever in their
little cabin
and uh and they seemed super nervous
and they're just he's like carrying the
gun around and all the animals are kind
of nervous outside and they're acting
really weird
and the kid's like what the [ __ ] going
i just know just go to bed and don't say
anything and then one of their neighbors
comes pounding and they're like help me
help me help me it's after me and
neither the parents like open the door
and he's just like what the [ __ ] why are
we not helping this guy he's our friend
and then so he ends up like looking out
the window and seeing this guy getting
killed by pumpkinhead like far away
so you're so they're establishing early
on
that ed harley uh knows that pumpkinhead
is
real yeah and knows that you can summon
him
to get revenge on somebody that's [ __ ]
you over in some way yeah he knew it
wasn't just a tale
yeah and then it's kind of cool like
like i said
i really liked the dialogue the dialogue
and the storytelling is very natural
all right um it does it's
some of the [ __ ] some of these movies
you see today the dialogue sounds
very disjointed and unnatural the
storytelling isn't very good
this is a very coherent story
even though the setting isn't that
believable like you know 1920s dust bowl
you know [ __ ] hillbillies and in in
in the late 80s in california no i
didn't have but
the characters are kind of believable
they say things that make sense
like um the hillbilly boy
he wanted to know whether or not this
[ __ ] pumpkin head was
real everybody's hiding in the hiding in
their little
shacks their hillbilly shacks his dad's
saying don't go outside you know and
he's like well what's it doing you know
is it real he thought they just made it
up to scared people yeah
and he's like no it's real but it'll
only kill who it's been summoned for
so it kind of he got kind of got
emboldened by that so he decided he was
going to sneak out
all right and he sneaks out to watch the
thing he's actually witnesses some
murders he sees
[ __ ] pumpkin head and what i liked is
like on several occasions every time he
ran
into people including ed harley first
thing out of his mouth was
pumpkin head's real yes i saw it
[Laughter]
and um he said that a couple of times to
different
which would which is totally normal
that's what a person would do
in those circumstances but it's rare
that a movie does that
yeah it's more like usually in a movie
the guy sees the monster
you saw it because you're in the
audience and it's not mentioned again
everybody has assumed that they're down
with it yes this is a reality because we
saw it on screen
now this kid was still tripping like you
know 20 minutes later i saw a pumpkin
and it's real
it's real did you see that [ __ ] it was
real i saw it which like you said that
is very realistic that's realistic
because that's what you'd be doing you'd
be running around all night telling
people i saw it it's real
and i made sure to put that in there
which makes the tail
more naturalistic and it's kind of
bringing you into it because
that's what you would expect you know
you're kind of buying into the reality
of this tale
even though it's a fictional [ __ ]
tale but you still buy into it you
invest in it
the whole thing of the witch wear the
damn pumpkinhead monster was buried in
the [ __ ] pumpkin patch
cemetery where they would bury the
people they were ashamed of just
just the whole [ __ ] the their i kind
of think though
i liked the movie a lot it held up over
the years
it's actually a hidden gem from the past
because there's a lot of good story in
this um
i think i would have changed one thing
but i can kind of understand why the
director did it but
i think i would have made it a period
piece i think i would have had
the whole thing take place in the early
1900s or the 20s
like hatfields and mccoy's type deal
yeah
but i think the reason why the director
did this is because
they wanted you to be afraid they wanted
you
to be worried about the city people okay
and and the only way to do that is to
get you to identify with them
so they had to be modern people like you
in the audience yeah
i think he felt that you wouldn't be
able to uh worry too much about
some middle-class people from the 1920s
yeah cause it's like you wouldn't be
able to identify with him
right you wouldn't you couldn't see
yourself in that so i think he says now
we're gonna have
kind of like the clash of two different
time periods
you know hillbillies and modern people
which that just didn't stand side by
side but in this apocryphal tale
it's just a it's just a witch story
witch and demon story
yeah pretty well like i said it's just
it's very folkloric and that's and
that's how i
took it yeah uh just kind of as a fairy
tale sort of sort of thing
i think i think my idea of a period
piece would have been really cool too
though
like it was something that happened a
long time ago yeah that might have been
cool but it's
it's always like uh especially with a
horror movie it's always kind of like
iffy doing a period piece because you're
going to turn off like a large segment
of the audience they're just like
i'm not watching something that took
place a long time ago right right
because they're always like people like
that
yeah um but i mean you know i don't mind
seeing period piece like horror movies
but in some ways
if this movie kind of reminded me of a
[ __ ] very
high caliber version of rawhead rex
remember rawhide is much better than
wrecks
but we like rawhead wrecks too say what
you will [ __ ] even though
they need to redo that with like a
better monster yeah well we talked about
rawhide
for several days and we're goofing on it
and talked about you know the the
the priest going baptize me and [ __ ]
raw heads breaks is [ __ ] pissing on
him and [ __ ]
we were just we were [ __ ] just uh you
know mystified by raw head rex
but we wanted it to be better yeah but
we could see that that will inform you
broadhead
yeah we see there was a lot of potential
there well yeah well the story is great
yeah it's just that the monster didn't
look that good i think that was
that was really what brought the whole
thing yeah had it been
had that monster been at the [ __ ]
level of the pumpkinhead outfit
and they shot it the right way that that
thing would have been really cool
i mean the idea the pumpkin head monster
looks
amazing yeah he looks amazing and they
do like like i said the full body shots
look
great the close-ups look great it's just
it doesn't look it looks like a real
creature it doesn't look like a person
in a suit
or animatronic or anything it looks like
a real creature you know it's definitely
there
well yeah big time so yeah so what ends
up happening you get that little
prologue and then it's like present day
and then you have lance hendrickson's
character ed harley
and his wife has died uh they don't say
how she died or when she died or
anything like that she's just dead
tuberculosis
they show him at the grave later on yeah
uh but he has this adorable little
moppet
of a son named billy and they have an
adorable little dog named gypsy who i
think i saw another review earlier that
pointed out that
that the dog that plays gypsy was the
same dog that was in gremlins so there
you go just that's a fun fact
i'm not sure if that's true but yeah so
uh so this kid's uh being adorable
and he obviously loves his son very much
and then
these troublesome city folk come along
they're not like
only one of them really is a douche the
rest of them are just kind of like along
for the ride and they're just normal
so i like that they didn't villainize
the whole group of them
it was just like the one dick because
there's you know always there was always
that one
yeah and they turned on him too though
yeah that's what i mean so so they also
turned on them so
what ends up happening is that they stop
at the store and they kind of make fun
of like oh look at these
backward ass people well he he mostly
does it the rest of them were like dude
shut up yeah you know what i mean the
kid's glasses yeah making fun of his
glasses and stuff i'm like making fun of
a kid yeah you're a big man whatever bro
so uh so then they hang out at this
store
and then because that guy wasn't being
obnoxious enough he's like hey let's get
our dirt bikes and just ride all over
with this grocery store is where
lance henriksen and his son like live
and opera well they don't live there but
that's like their store
and it so happens that lance has to go
i keep calling him lance because that's
the thing
ed hardy ed harley harley yeah so um
not ed hardy that's a t-shirt but um so
he has to go
like take something to to a neighbor and
the kid stays at the store runs out
after the dog and one of the dirt bikes
accidentally they don't kill him on
purpose uh accidentally ends up hitting
the little boy
yeah he comes he he did a ramp and came
down and landed on the kid
yeah kip was running after the dog yeah
he came out of nowhere
but dude panicked because he had been he
drank a few beers before he was do
did that and he was already on probation
for some other [ __ ] so he wanted to run
for yeah cause i think he had done a hit
and run before or he had done something
they said he did something to a girl
like a girl was another car since she'd
been hurt
yeah so he was already kind of in
trouble i'm not going to prison yeah so
he was basically like you know
we're not telling anybody anything and
we're taking off when we're going to the
cabin
and his that other guy that was like his
brother he was like you know
bro that's not cool and it's like so he
actually said his brother stayed
yeah he stayed with the kid until um you
know ed harley comes back
and ed is a little put out by the fact
that they've killed his
uh beloved son well he was alive when he
found him though yeah barely
yeah now there's one little hole here i
was like wait wait hold on
why didn't they rush the kid they had
multiple vehicles they could have rushed
the kid but
see that's what the guy said on sinister
cinema it's like why didn't they i was
like well maybe there wasn't a hospital
like within
several hours of there because i know
there are actually some places now where
there's which maybe ed harley wouldn't
have wanted vengeance if they if they'd
rushed him to the hospital
yeah if they tried to like yeah because
he didn't see what happened he wasn't
there
uh obviously he's a little uh upset by
this
and not really thinking [ __ ] through so
the first thing he thinks to do like
when his
son and ends up like dying in his arms
is
uh i'm gonna summon pumpkinhead yeah and
take these [ __ ] out
yeah now the the little uh
hillbilly kid the boy he's probably
about 16 17.
he's got some cute little sisters they
make sure to do the uh
to do the uh the ellie may clamp it
[ __ ] thing to show the sister he
sleeps in the same room where there
river
she was cute but uh
he uh ed harley goes to him and asks him
where to find the the old lady well he
asked the dad first yeah
dad wouldn't tell him well the dad said
i'm not gonna tell you because that's
it's not it's like one for you she can't
bring anybody back from the dead
and you're not gonna like how shit's
gonna turn out like she's got nothing
she won't do nothing for you
nothing good for you and well the boy
jumped out later on when
he was always going around his dad's
back you know and
told him where it was and then ed hardy
says you're going to take me there
i'm going there that woman scares me
steers the [ __ ] out of me
so he goes and meets the meets the witch
and she lives in an old damn witch shack
and it's
with he's got [ __ ] owl in there and
everything there and skulls
it's awesome when he comes in and he's
dropping silver coins kind of like
california used silver coins for
currency
he's some kind of spanish doubloons or
something we'll see well it wouldn't be
cool if you just
gave her cash yeah can i write you a
cheque
that's what i mean it's not
you need like that at that halloween
creepy folklore atmosphere like to make
it work
he comes in with it she didn't even look
at him she's sitting that wrong
she's a witch man she walks in behind
her and he goes
ain't nothing i can do i can't raise the
deadhead harley
i got nothing for you you know then
finally he starts talking about
vengeance you know and pumpkin head and
she's like well on that score i can help
you
yeah yeah yeah she's like it's a high
price to pay at harley
all kind of weird [ __ ] you know doesn't
it
yeah and he's like you know [ __ ] she
goes go out to the pumpkin patch and
then
you'll see it dig it up take a shovel
dig it up bring it back here
and he goes okay he leaves because leave
the boy and he's like well
he leave the boy he's a dead boy there
and he came back he
goes out to the pumpkin patches spooky
ass places this big old [ __ ] tree
stuff he's gotta climb up on top of it
and it's it's hollow with some dirt and
he starts digging digs up old rotten ass
corpse it's all curled up
you don't nearly throwing up he takes it
back to the shack
and she's talking about him you know and
she cuts his hand and
puts it where she she puts a blood in a
bowl and put the boy's blood in the bowl
yeah and then poured it on the down
on the on the baby pumpkin baby pumpkin
head and it just
immediately [ __ ] starts
[Laughter]
yeah that's pretty cool it gets big when
it needs to you go home man
it'll be down you know nothing else to
do with you yeah yeah yeah
we'll see okay so the the problem is yes
you know somebody [ __ ] you over so you
know this kid this guy killed your kid
and didn't take him to the hospital and
is and kind of took off and left the
scene which is shitty
um so he decides in in his grief
understandably so i'm gonna kill these
[ __ ]
um so you go you summon the demon
and uh but apparently there's like a
little asterisk on that when you summon
the vengeance demon
okay so it doesn't just i think that he
thought
that pumpkinhead was just gonna go kill
all these people and then bob's your
uncle everyone's gonna go about their
day
and that's not how [ __ ] goes yeah and
then
the money he paid was just for the
[ __ ] witch
to summon the demon on his behalf the
demon had its own price too
you had to pay both in the end yes and i
don't know if we should spoil it all but
i don't know it's old
i mean it's 88. a lot of these
youngsters haven't seen it
and i mean i feel like it kind of has a
whole this [ __ ] movie had three
sequels
it had a sequel pumpkin had two blood
wings that was the second one
i don't know um the third one was called
ashes to ashes i think and the fourth
one was called blood feud
those two i think were made to like
direct for sci-fi yeah uh so those were
like tv movies they might be all right
i've heard the second one's okay but i
don't think i've ever seen it like the
third and fourth ones i don't think were
very good
yeah so this monster goes out this demon
goes out and starts killing off all
these
city folk downside of it is that ed
harley has to see it happen he has to
experience it through the damn eyes of
the [ __ ] demon
yeah he runs back to the witch and she's
like man we got to stop it it's going to
kill them all we got to stop it
too late for that at harley
gotta let it run its cars down all that
kind of [ __ ] he goes but i gotta
i'm seeing it oh you thought it'd be
easy they would just go out and do it
and you could just sit
back at home yeah yeah that's not how
[ __ ] because i'm gonna kill myself and
he goes and then you'll just pay the
final price
a lot sooner because you know because
second pumpkin head had its price too
and that's that's uh you're gonna be the
next pumpkin head after you die
and you're gonna pumpkin damn you which
damn you god damn you witches oh he
already has
it all right that witch was so [ __ ]
yeah i need to get me a witch wig
i want to see a whole movie about that
witch i'll just dress up as a witch and
do the way i eat
i love it like i said i love that she
has a witch shack
with like an out because if i was an old
witch like that i would totally have a
witch shack and like with owls and rats
and [ __ ] in there
and she just ran into this yeah
tarantula oh yeah there's tarantulas in
there too
and she just like sits there looking at
the fire and waits for somebody to come
in
and like to summon pumpkin head and that
she didn't even like turn around to look
at you she already knows what you want
yeah and then she's going to tell you
like all this witchy wisdom type of [ __ ]
and she's bringing back the dead eating
my powers that are they
oh my god they're funny but yeah so so
the thing about it i think
see i think what happens with lance
henriksen is that
you know yes he said yeah i want
vengeance when he wasn't really thinking
[ __ ] through because i mean his son had
just died and he was like flipping out
about it
so he just he did it very rashly
but then after he thought about it for a
second because
for a second he does see like a you know
he sees his dead son like sitting up in
his car being like daddy what did you do
or something like that
so he's starting to regret it like
almost immediately but then i think that
when pumpkinhead starts going around
killing all the city folks
and he realizes that he's gonna have to
see everything that happens
through pumpkinhead's eyes he's gonna
have to like it's almost like he's
murdering them with his own hands
um he kind of cools on the idea a little
bit you wouldn't just see it he was
feeling it
yeah i think he was kind of experiencing
it like he was doing it
well you start crumpling up and crawling
across the ground and stuff so because
the closer they get to the end of the
movie the more him and pumpkinhead start
resembling each other
um you know because pumpkin had if you
if you didn't notice and i don't think i
noticed this the first time i saw it
but as as the movie goes on the pumpkin
head monster the face starts looking
more and more like lance henriksen
like the face around the face yeah and
his face starts to look more like the
pumpkin head face
yeah he starts looking more demonically
he's got like red eyes and [ __ ] like
kind of like
spiritually merging with one another
yeah which makes sense because like i
said their blood was mixed and he was
the one that had summoned him
and like you said um you know if you
summon pumpkinhead
yes it'll do what you want it to do but
just like any time you're
using black magic don't advise like we
don't advise it because
it's always going to bite you in the ass
and it bites him in the ass in this one
as well
general rule with black magic is that
the price or the cost for [ __ ]
using it is equal or greater than the
damage or what
that you did to your enemy yeah so you
have to be able to absorb
all that [ __ ] pain yeah so that
that's you know
when you think about it it's a lot like
george lucas
and star wars with the damn sith in
those sith
video games you can do all this wicked
[ __ ] but it damages you so you have to
learn to deal with damage and suffering
yeah and so which is
all [ __ ] up and likes it they're kind
of like sadomasochistic
yeah she's like yeah [ __ ] that yeah yeah
yeah i'm into it yeah
pretty much witches and sith are the
same thing
yeah pretty much yeah but yeah so it
turns out um you know when he starts to
regret it now
a bunch of the kids do get killed um you
know only one of whom really kind of
deserved it
but like you said i was you know the
whole point of the movie
is vengeance is never worth it won't
bring back the debt it wouldn't bring
the boy back
and a bunch of uh innocent people got
killed
yeah uh just because they were hanging
out with us happened to be hanging out
with this one douche when there was an
accident
yep and then ed harley was con his soul
was condemned to hell
that too and he had to serve as the next
[ __ ] pumpkin head demon
yeah so that's a heavy price
so was it worth it no and he paid the
witch to hook all this up for him so it
was a heavy heavy price yeah
it just seemed like it wasn't worth it
in the end it's it's a
it is a morality tale yeah that too like
i said it was it's just a very like a
very cool like folkloric i think it was
based on a poem originally
yeah and that might have been the poem
that they're reciting like all the kids
when they first come to the you know
like that
dude that has the gaggle of children one
of those kids was actually um
what's her face uh maya bialik who was
on she was on blossom
and then that's kind of where she got
her star making turn and then she was on
what's that [ __ ]
sitcom with all the nerds god damn it
that's just
i can't remember what it's called but uh
that one that was like really popular a
couple years ago she was she's on that
as well
um what the [ __ ] is that called [ __ ] man
i can't remember but yeah she was on
that too so she's like super famous
but that she was like a little kid in
this so she was i don't think she even
has any lines or hard landing lines
but she's one of the gaggle of children
but yeah so this movie
like you said it really holds up one
because
all the effects are practical uh two the
cinematic it looks really nice
it looks like this is a good halloween
movie yeah it's very creepy and foggy
the acting and the storytelling is
really good yeah good score
um the story makes sense
and all the dialogue makes sense the
only thing that is kind of feels a
little bit contrived is that
you think that they would have rushed
the kid to the hospital but had they
done that it would have foiled the whole
story
yeah you know what i mean so that's why
they did that and like i said maybe that
was another thing like why they made it
this
insular like out of nowhere out in the
middle of nowhere community because
maybe that was the thing maybe they
didn't have a hospital
yeah type of thing that would have made
more sense if it was a period piece back
in the 20s there had been nowhere to
take him
not the amount of time yeah that's true
the only criticism i can give this i
feel like it needed more
gore it did it also it needed some more
people to kill needed a little bit more
action and
uh the final conflict between
it kind of ended ends a little abruptly
i think i would have lighted
liked another 10 10 minutes maybe of
them kind of fighting
fighting yeah yeah and things happening
and pumpkinhead doing certain things
i could see that yeah well like i said
it does sound it it does seem strange
that
you know since this was a stan winston
you know him directing it
and he's kind of like the effects guy
and like i said the pumpkinhead monster
looks
great i just so but it seems like a lot
of the kills
were kind of like not as gory as i was
expecting
you know what i'm saying yeah i don't
think it was r rated it might not have
been i don't think it was i think it was
pg
i mean basically he i mean what
pumpkinhead would do he would just grab
you by the face which is pretty rad
and a lot of times he would just kind of
like pick you up and drop it and drop
you from like a tree
or that one the i think the best kill
was that one girl
that he basically took her face and like
pushed it into a window very
very suspicious dropped the other one
then he there was one where uh guy
jumped on a motorcycle he picked the
whole motorcycle and dude and do it yeah
he was like
get his ass he he lived though yeah he
ended up living
he was kind of [ __ ] up though because
i think pumpkin had also kind of stepped
on him
but uh yeah so oh and the one guy the
the main douchey guy who i feel like
they should have saved him for last but
i guess they wanted a couple people to
survive
so um because otherwise what would have
been the point cause it was like well
they're all dead now so it's like you
know
um so there wouldn't have been anybody
for lance hendrickson to save
by doing what he did uh but that guy
he got impaled by a ch shotgun
yeah no it was a rifle or a rifle yeah
yeah he got a bolt-action rifle yeah
there you go so he got impaled by that
and then pumpkin had like picked him up
by it it was like right
he shot pumpkin with head with it twice
shot him in the body and when it fell
down he went up there and shot it in the
head it didn't do anything to him though
well of course he's a demon yeah i mean
duh i thought he thought he killed it it
was playing dead
that's what i mean it was funny we were
watching this last night i was like dude
if you've never seen a horror movie
don't ever
ever walk up to like the [ __ ] dead
monster or murder or anything because
he's just gonna grab your [ __ ] ankle
and that indeed that's exactly what
happened yeah
uh and and like i said i wouldn't assume
honestly like if
if you realize that's why i was like
gonna say when you were saying about
that kid
uh telling everybody it's like
pumpkinhead's real because that's what
you would be like if you
if there was like an urban legend that
you had heard your whole life and you
just thought it was a story and it's
super creepy but then like one night you
actually saw the [ __ ] and you thought
and you'd be like
you would [ __ ] a brick right yeah and um
if that happened
i would not assume that you could just
shoot it and kill it
yeah i would assume that i just need to
run the [ __ ] away
like it's because i don't even know how
to like because you wouldn't know what
the [ __ ]
that was so i would just assume like i
said it's a demon
so yeah i would i would think a gun
wouldn't work that guy was a city kid
though he had no idea what that was
never they didn't know that was a demon
or had anything to do with witchcraft
that's true yeah everybody is a big
being everybody in the town
knew yeah because everybody knows that
legend he just thought it was a big
monster
yeah you know maybe an alien or
something which yeah i guess that's what
you would think of you shot is this dead
yeah shouted again well at least he did
do the double tap yeah so you can give
him that credit for that
because i feel like in a lot of 80s
horror movies they were just like
assumed
yeah and i'm just like why don't you cut
his hat off do something it's like just
don't
you know what i mean you got to make
sure so he did double tap yeah he
coulda grabbed it it's over
it grabbed him nope afraid not yeah i
was just playing dead so i could [ __ ]
you up he did with a high power rifle
you know like 308 or something
i liked too that even though that guy
that guy's douchiness
uh was the thing that started the whole
thing and got pretty much all his
friends killed
but i liked that as the movie went on he
actually did start feeling bad
even before everybody started turning up
dead you know uh because he was like no
i'm not going to jail and then he got in
a bunch of fights with it and he like
locked a couple people in the closet
because he didn't want them going to the
cops
and all this other stuff but as time
went on he actually did
be like yeah maybe i should turn myself
in you know because his brother was kind
of telling him hey once you do the right
thing it's like
it was just an accident well no it
wouldn't have but well that's the dumb
thing is that
had he just come forward and said yeah
it was an accident yeah i understand why
he didn't because he's like yeah i'm
already on probation for like some other
similar [ __ ]
and so he would have gotten in trouble
and gone to jail but then the fact that
he just kept compounding
yeah like he even like beat the [ __ ] out
of his friend like with a log or
something and it's just kind of like so
he just kept doing it like he left the
scene they could have got some more
action out of the movie head he kind of
like i said manned up tried to be a hero
and try to save some people and actually
had him
fight it out with pumpkin head and maybe
kind of like
hold his own against pumpkin head or
fool pumpkin head a couple of times and
make you think that well maybe they do
have a chance
yeah see because i always had the
feeling that they had no chance
well i could yeah and and so that was
kind of one thing i could kind of
criticize about it
it you immediately get the feeling that
that it's that there's no hope that that
there's no way to fight this thing there
was
in the end but but there wasn't anything
they could do there wasn't anything they
could do
and they should have made you believe
that yeah that maybe you
could that it could be hurt that it
could be hurt or it could be bested
somehow
yeah that way you could invest a little
more
or maybe they'll make it but i was under
the impression that they were goners
from day one
well yeah as soon as you summon pumpkin
head you're just kind of
oh so they should i think maybe they
should have had some more combat
between it i wonder if they left would
pumpkin head still be able to pumpkin
head have a range i don't think he does
i mean as a demon you would think not i
think he would have followed you
i have so many questions maybe some of
this stuff was addressed in the uh
sequels maybe we should watch those and
see what's going
on because i i'm kind of i love the the
just folkloric
as an aspect of like a vengeance demon
that looks like that that comes out of a
pumpkin patch i mean that's [ __ ] rad
this summoned by a witch
yeah i love it i love that [ __ ] but yeah
so uh if you haven't seen pumpkinhead i
can't believe
most of you haven't seen it but probably
have like i said it came out in 1988
uh it's on 2b at the moment for free and
i think it might also be on amazon prime
if you like alien or aliens terminator
like that
80s monster movies if you like 80s
monsters monster movies and you haven't
seen it then your quality is very good
yeah it just it looks good um you know
the monsters
terrific it's just it's i don't know
it's just a really fun
80s monster movie yeah so go watch it
right now
alright that'll do it for this movie
retrospective we will see you guys on
the next one
bye